[Musica]
da noi o no d'alessio fir qual è il
limite delle nostre ambizioni
quanto siamo disposti a rischiare per
avere successo
cosa deve accadere perché arriviamo al
punto di dire basta siamo andati troppo
oltre
o ancora meglio quando arriva in
un'impresa quel momento in cui davvero
dici ci siamo spinti troppo oltre
ad oggi forse la più grande impresa che
la razza umana intrapreso è stata quella
di spingersi oltre i luoghi che le
permettono la vita oltre la propria
atmosfera sulla superficie della luna
per noi oggi può sembrare una cosa di
routine andare nello spazio e forse
questo di neanche la nostra zona di
rischio oggi in fondo ci faremo molti
meno problemi a salire su una navicella
di non mask per fare un paio di giorni
nello spazio negli anni 60 le cose erano
ben diverse quando nasce pard è partito
per la prima missione americana nello
spazio ad esempio il razzo su cui è
salito esplodeva la metà delle volte in
cui veniva acceso forse non ci serve un
economista per dirci la percentuale di
rischio di un'impresa simile
questo è quello che si fronteggiano però
in quell'epoca un incontro a tu per tu
con le proprie paure i pericoli le
grandi ambizioni e soprattutto il fuoco
se vi chiedessero qual è la cosa che mi
fa più paura di un razzo molti direbbero
il fuoco in fondo un razzo che parte non
è altri che un enorme gigantesca
esplosione
estremamente controllata però ecco e se
il razzo non avesse ancora il carburante
ci sarebbe lo stesso il pericolo prima
di mandare una navicella nello spazio
per esempio solitamente si effettuavano
molti test ed in particolare nel periodo
delle missioni apollo questi venivano
effettuati all'interno del vero razzo
posto sulla rampa di lancio ovviamente
senza il carburante
il 27 gennaio del 1967 a che tra una
canaveral in florida si sta effettuando
proprio uno di questi test e dentro il
modo di comando di apollo 1 ci sono tre
astronauti gas russo e dwight e roger
cioffi il test però sta procedendo male
le comunicazioni tra la navicella il
centro di controllo hanno le lente
e sono tutti un po spazientiti assopiti
alle 18 31 però poche parole
riecheggiano nelle cuffie di tutti fuoco
c'è del fuoco a bordo in un attimo il
fuoco divampa all'interno della cabina
pressurizzata di apollo una la nasa per
la prima volta nella storia perde degli
astronauti a bordo di una sua navicella
quando la tua più grande paura è perdere
gli astronauti nello spazio
quando questo avviene a pochi metri da
te tende a vedere le cose con una
prospettiva diversa
qui però c'è da capire in una cosa
importante il rapporto tra gli
astronauti i tecnici dirigenti della
nasa il personale servizio tutti non era
qualcosa che possiamo minimamente
immaginare avete mai provato a pensare
ad un intera nazione che è completamente
dedicata anima e corpo allo stesso scopo
è molto difficile pensarla così è
qualcosa che nessuno riesce a figurarsi
davvero il legame che si crea è
indissolubile gli animi sono puntati
tutti nella stessa direzione
fondamentalmente si vince e purtroppo si
perde assieme
quel giorno verso prodotti
però come si può andare avanti dopo una
tragedia del genere come si può rimanere
indifferenti e decidere di tornare in
sella per qualcosa di così pericoloso in
molti pensavano di mollare tutto le
critiche sulle essersi già spinti troppo
oltre c'erano fondamentalmente si stava
andando troppo veloci senza pensare alla
sicurezza
beh in questi casi ognuno alle proprie
ragioni
io vi dico alcune volte lo si fa per
rendere importante il sacrificio di
coloro che hanno dato la vita per quel
sogno ma torniamo a noi quello che
successe quel giorno in florida fu
qualcosa di non isolato ma se ripercorse
per mesi su tutti uno degli esempi
principali dei complotti lunari spesso
più famosi è quello che riguarda
l'allora direttore della nasa jim webb
ecco gv in quel periodo dovette
onestamente fare di tutto davvero di
tutto cose di cui probabilmente non
andava fiero per riuscire a tenere in
piedi il programma spaziale e arrivare
sulla luna qualcosa che lo distrusse
dove su sesta al punto da fargli basta a
poco dal raggiungimento dell'obiettivo
questo per farvi capire la gravità di
quell'evento però c'era un'altra persona
quel giorno in ascolto dei ragazzi e
questa era dix layton vik era stato uno
dei miei arco di seven i primi
astronauti che la nasa aveva selezionato
per andare nello spazio purtroppo però
col progredire degli esami medici era
stata scoperta una malformazione al
cuore che gli aveva tolto la possibilità
di andare nello spazio
tuttavia resta una mente competente nel
suo lavoro e quindi era stato messo a
capo della strana toffees in pratica era
quello che sceglieva chi andava nello
spazio e chi no di che aveva scelto
personalmente quell'equipaggio e per una
buona ragione aveva fatto i calcoli
quando sarebbero arrivati sulla luna
avrebbe voluto che ci fosse uno della
mercury sopra la navicella uno dei primi
astronauti per dare un segnale forte e
quindi aveva deciso che gas sarebbe
stato il primo a salire sulla pollo così
probabilmente il suo secondo volo quello
successivo sarebbe poi stato quello
decisivo per il programma
pensateci quei tre astronauti erano lì
per la gloria
qual è il colpo di scena di questa
storia però vi state chiedendo in fondo
una storia per essere appassionante deve
averne uno
beh questo appartiene a tre donne
formidabili ovvero betti grissom
patricia finnegan e marta forme le tre
mogli degli astronauti dell'apollo 1
vedete qualche giorno dopo l'incidente
dell'apollo le tre donne chiamarono di
che gli chiedono di passare a casa di
betty senza quasi lasciarlo parlare si
misero di fronte a lui eni forse una
scatolina come quella che contengono
quelle che contengono gli anelli di
fidanzamento avete presente bene di
capri e al suo interno c'era una spilla
una spilla d'oro da astronauta con sulla
sommità un piccolo diamante
bene dic rimasi perplesso all'inizio è
quasi in coro le tre donne gli
spiegarono che consideravano come uno di
loro avrebbero voluto dartelo al ritorno
dal missione vedete per gli astronauti
esiste una tradizione che vive sin dagli
anni 60 ovvero quando completano
l'addestramento viene data loro una
piccola spilla d'argento questa poi deve
essere obbligatoriamente sostituita e
qui deve sborsare l'astronauta con una
in oro quando si effettua la prima vera
missione nello spazio
i ragazzi conoscevano bene dic e
sapevano che non avrebbe mai accettato
una spilla come la loro perché in fondo
non se l'era guadagnata per cui viene
fecero una assolutamente unica tutta per
lui di clima se scioccato da quello che
ricevette quel giorno ed è rimasto al
suo posto fino a che non abbiamo
conquistato la luna è stato seduto ogni
singolo giorno alla sua scrivania con la
sua spilla a fare tutto ciò che fosse in
suo potere per far sì che il sogno che
aveva condiviso con gas ed è roger non
si spegnesse mai
inoltre ci sono due cose da sapere
ancora la spilla di vik prima di tutto
in allora dell'equipaggio di apollo 1
volo nel kit personale di neil armstrong
nel luglio del 1969 fino alla luna su
apollo 11 e poi che dic invece decide di
cambiar vita
si comincia allenare tantissimo smise di
fumare sconfisse la sua malattia al
cuore e nel 1973
andrò nello spazio con il programma
apollo su news come astronauta vedete
questa storia un fondo per come la vedo
io che non è quello del cordoglio bensì
della forza che hanno i grandi obiettivi
tre astronauti sono periti nel 1967 oggi
quelle tre persone nessuno le ha
scordate oggi sono diventati il monito
per andare incontro alle paure e alle
difficoltà per raggiungere qualcosa di
più grande il luogo dove scoppia
l'incendio oggi campeggiano due targhe
in memoria dei tre astronauti che sono
mobili
una di esse recita complesso di lancio
numero 34 venerdì 27 gennaio
1967 ore 18 31 dedicata alla memoria
dell'equipaggio di apollo 1 tenente
colonnello virtue gas che il tenente
colonnello ed white capitano di corvetta
roger ciaffi diedero la loro vita al
servizio del loro paese per la continua
esplorazione della frontiera finale
dell'umanità non siano ricordati per la
loro morte ma per gli ideali per cui
hanno vissuto
di più cose veniamo a conoscenza di me
non avremo paura e queste sono le parole
l'astronauta presenti grazie